imagine a world where every drop of
water counts welcome to the future of
smart farming with the ingenious water
technique a revolutionary approach it
maximizes efficiency by ensuring not a
single drop is wasted picture a farm
where sensors monitor soil moisture
guiding irrigation systems to water only
when and where it's needed this
technique not only conserves our
precious Water Resources but also
maintains optimal soil Health leading to
higher crop yields the blend of
technology and sustainability it's
changing the face of Agriculture making
farming smarter Greener and more
efficient it's not just about growing
food it's about growing with care for
our planet this is the power of smart
farming water technique ensuring every
drop counts for a sustainable and
fruitful future